you gotta get over the need to be liked
by everyone because going on the
internet I promise you you're just
reaching the whole world you have
everyone in the world that has a chance
to watch your video I promise you not
everyone's gonna like you you need
courage to persist and to be more
convicted about your own passions
beliefs values and reasons for starting
on YouTube rather than what somebody
else thinks about your content
hey welcome back to the think media
podcast Sean Cannell here and I want to
thank you so much for joining me for
this two-part series about the seven C's
of YouTube success this episode is
brought to you by
ytsecrets.com the second edition of
YouTube Secrets is out now and we'll
talk a little bit more about that later
but let's jump into the first C and that
is courage
[Music]
so you probably realize by now that
punching fear in the face starting a
YouTube channel and consistently posting
content can be overwhelming it can be
kind of scary and it also can be
frustrating because you're not sure how
to get views you're not sure how to grow
and personally I know exactly how you
feel I remember when I posted my first
video poop your pants scared armpit
sweaty nervous to put myself out there
on YouTube but today I've now posted
thousands of videos I've gotten over 200
million views on YouTube and now I've
helped tens of thousands of people
really build the confidence to get on
camera and succeed with YouTube and I
created a seven step really YouTube
formula for success and I talk about
that in my book YouTube secrets that
actually just launched with the second
edition but I want to break down all
seven of those steps so you can go from
confusion to Clarity so you can go from
frustration to actually building some
math massive momentum when it comes to
getting views on YouTube and we call
these these seven C's of YouTube success
and the first one is courage you got to
start before you're ready now of course
there's all kinds of tactics and you
gotta have great titles and thumbnails
and how do you make videos but the truth
that I've noticed that holds most people
back is actually this first C courage
you gotta overcome the fear of what
other people think I've heard the the
phrase fopo the acronym fopo f-o-p-o it
stands for the fear of other people's
opinions the truth is one of the hardest
obstacles to overcome when getting on
YouTube is the fear of what other people
think and there's a lot of excuses that
come up and so the reason the first C is
courage is because a lot of times we
might say ah I'm too I'm too old to
start YouTube or I'm too young to start
YouTube a lot of other excuses people
have I don't have the time to do this
you have to actually overcome all of
those excuses really stop making excuses
and say I'm just gonna start getting
results I'm not gonna let time Hold Me
Back My Age hold me back you have to
have the courage to get on camera and
then when you play back that video you
have to hear your own voice and you're
probably not going to like it right I
remember back before cell phones before
iPhones before Razer flip phones we used
to have answering machines right I had a
landline and I remember when I would
maybe call home leave my mom my dad a
message but then I beat them home right
they hadn't listened to it yet so I went
home and I pressed play on the answer
machine and I heard my own voice and I
was like what the heck is that is that
what I actually sound like is that what
my voice sounds like what's worse is now
you think about video you play the video
back you're like is that what I actually
look like dear God you know somebody
help and so ultimately these are all
mindset courage things that hold us back
you gotta have the courage to start
before you're ready you gotta have the
courage to punch fear in the face you
gotta have courage to embrace criticism
and negative comments
see the first C of the Seven Seas of
YouTube success is the courage to
actually start posting content whether
or not
you're going to get judgment or negative
criticism and here's the deal I promise
you that if you start posting content on
the internet and if you achieve your
stated goal Sean I would love to get a
thousand subscribers 10 000 subscribers
100 000 subscribers and get a silver
play button if you get a hundred
thousand subscribers there's definitely
going to be a few people on the journey
who don't like you or they don't like
your content and honestly it's probably
not even that person uh personal but
they'll stop by your video and they'll
be like why is your hair weird why I
remember I got a comment once and they
said why do you have the face of a boy
but the hair of an old man I was like
wow thanks I guess the gray is coming in
pretty strong right now people are just
going to say things that can kind of be
hurtful but you have to decide
that your mission is more important than
the criticism You Gotta Have Courage you
got to have a Clear Vision for why you
want to start your YouTube channel and
you have to have the courage of put
punching fear in the face and getting
out there there's a lot of fears that
come up you know when you're starting
YouTube the fear of being judged the
fear of not being an expert the fear
that uh somebody else is going to judge
you if you say something wrong if you if
you say something wrong about the
content you're making the product you're
talking about in the video you know I'm
a tech reviewer I remember on think
media once I um I was reading the box of
an Asus monitor and it said IPS which is
a particular type of uh Monitor and it
stands for in panel switching but
literally on the box it said image
perfecting screen and so I was reading
off the box and and I guess I wasn't
really wrong but I wasn't saying the
technical term of of ips and wouldn't
you know every tech nerd and geek on the
internet and I would include myself in
that cat category but apparently you
know I made a mistake and and I was torn
to shreds people in the comments like
look at this guy he doesn't even know
what IPS stands for
and I got all these comments about it
and I'll tell you I'll admit I kind of
thought should I take the video down I
kind of thought oh my gosh I made a
mistake this kind of stuff is the stuff
that bothers me I'm in the shower like
thinking about oh I can't believe I said
that wrong I'm laying in bed I should be
focusing like you know on my wife but
I'm like thinking about Critics on
YouTube like this is real stuff that's
gonna come your way so my hope is that
in this podcast you can muster and
commit to and realize that you gotta
just summon the next level of courage to
get on YouTube and one of the things I
discovered was even though I see critics
in the comments of my YouTube videos I
have never run into those critics at the
bank
yeah like I didn't take the video down
and guess what the video actually has
hundreds of thousands of views now with
a handful of negative comments but I
still got all that AdSense I got
affiliate marketing from the product I
was talking about it was a good video
overall listen we're humans we're going
to make mistakes so even on my journey
to being a tech tech expert or a YouTube
expert or whatever your Niche is listen
you gotta just put videos out there of
course do your due diligence and put
your best work in and put your research
in I mean I'm giving it my best I'm
trying my hardest but no matter what you
do you're never gonna please everybody
see this thing takes courage you got to
get over the need to be liked by
everyone because going on the internet I
promise you you're just reaching the
whole world you have everyone in the
world that has a chance to watch your
video I promise you not everyone's gonna
like you you need courage to persist and
to be more convicted about your own
passions beliefs values and reasons for
starting on YouTube rather than what
somebody else thinks about your content
there's too much fear out there people
are afraid of saying the wrong thing of
upsetting others people are afraid of
getting canceled Sean can you promise me
that I won't get canceled I can't
promise you anything but I can promise
you that if you don't take action you're
always going to wonder why
you know what's worse like the pain of
some negative comments or the pain of
regret from never even starting in the
first place friend it's time to start
before you're ready the first C of the
seven C's of YouTube success is courage
you gotta punch fear in the face and
press record you know a couple other
things I notice under courage is is you
know just putting yourself on the
Internet is scary and so well Sean what
if I get hacked what if I get stalked
these are good questions what if I get
hacked I think you should use something
like one password
I think you should use something that
you should definitely have a good
password always enable two-factor
authentication when setting up your
YouTube channel that'll really help you
from getting hacked be careful with who
you share information with don't just
you know really share your login
information
um indiscriminately change your password
often and if you use a password created
by software like uh LastPass or one
password then um you're going to be in a
lot better position and definitely don't
just use that password that you were
still using in high school for your
Hotmail account you know 10 years later
that that password is on the dark web
486 times and so it's probably time to
change your password and then of course
like fear of getting stocked listen you
don't have to use maybe your last name
maybe use a brand name maybe you change
your name like got to be wise don't put
your address out there you know like you
can decide whether or not you want to
show your family or your kids there are
answers to every objection you're
bringing up
well Sean I'm just not ready to start
yet you're never going to be ready you
got to just start
well Sean what if I get stalked fair
question and I want to be sensitive to
that issue but again you got to just put
yourself out there put security measures
in place get an alarm you know do things
to be anonymous
take to be serious about this but if we
always think about every possible
scenario of what we what can go wrong
we'd never leave the house we would
never ultimately take action you know in
Proverbs it actually talks about it says
the lazy man says there's a lion outside
so he never goes outside it's like
there's just always something uh today's
not a good day it might rain today is
not a good day the stock market's down
oh today's not a good day you know there
might be some negativity like no that
for sure there's never
gonna be the perfect time and fair
weather you know never made a skilled
sailor it takes courage to get
uncomfortable and start on YouTube and
you got to overcome the fear of the Gear
Well Sean when I'm ready and I
understand Tech and I understand my
camera and I understand how to make it
look good when I watch think media Nolan
and Omar's videos they just they look
too good I can't even I can't do that
yeah when you're starting you don't know
the tech yet you got fear of the gear
but you have to start anyways get that
50 webcam grab that flashlight as your
only lighting Source you know just start
because once you start moving you can
improve as you go I've learned this you
can't steer a parked car
the first C of the Seven Seas of YouTube
success is courage you have to start
before you're ready you got to start
moving because once you start moving the
rest of the tips once you start moving
the rest of the strategies they actually
work but you can't just sit there and
just absorb a bunch of information and
take no action and expect to get results
friend it's time to summon a new level
of Courage oh but Sean I don't have
enough money to do this friend if you're
watching this video you can start
because you're either watching this on a
smartphone you're listening to this from
your phone or in your car and at home
you got a laptop or you got a computer
or your friend does or your partner does
or you could go borrow one like there's
a way to figure out how to do this see
I've learned it actually really isn't
about your resources it's about your
resourcefulness
so you just got to get resourceful oh
yeah okay I do have these obstacles I do
have these setbacks I do have these
challenges I do have that crazy X I do
have that stuff in that situation but
I'm going to be resourceful I'm going to
be wise I'm going to be cautious but I'm
going to be courageous
so I hope you're fired up because we
just covered the first C of the seven
C's of YouTube success and I wanted to
devote an entire episode to it because
courage is so important but definitely
make sure you're subscribed wherever you
listen to or watch this podcast so that
you can catch part two where I'm gonna
share the next six C's of these seven C
YouTube success formula and listen
today's episode is brought to you by
ytsecrets.com that's the letter y the
letter T and the word secrets.com the
second edition of YouTube Secrets is out
now and if you haven't picked up the
book and you want to learn more about
this plus 80 new pages of content three
new chapters new data new stats the
entire book updated a whole appendix
full of resources I highly recommend
grabbing the book you can check it out
links in the description or at the URL
ytsecrets.com and I think it'll serve
you if you also like listening to it on
audio it is also out on audible smash
like or leave a review on Apple podcast
if you enjoyed this episode and I'm
excited to see you in the next one
[Music]